Oh Gott! Oh Moment! Irgendwie ist das Kabel total verdinkt hier. Warte mal, ich muss das mal rausmachen.
So exquisite! Soll ich noch kurz Musik für Sie leiser machen? So alles klar. Mal gucken, ob heute das Sound wieder so ist wie gestern.
Anscheinend ist das Sound wieder so wie gestern. Wait a minute. Hab ich die Aussetze oder so? Oder ist die Anzeige kacke?
Windows Sound Settings. Alter, ich bekomme Anfälle. Warum macht da überhaupt... Nee, passt doch. Warum macht Windows da überhaupt Dinger dran, Alter?
Ich fasse es nicht. Ich fasse es nicht. Stimmt. Na gut. Ich habe heute aber auch rumgebastelt, was Audio Zeug angeht.
Also vielleicht... Nee, bei Windows Settings habe ich nichts eingestellt. Ich checke es nicht. Da machst du nichts. Ja. Also Leute.
Ist mir zu anstrengend. Heute Stream bis Bettke. So sieht es aus. So ist richtig. Stream bis Bettke. Und ihr wisst, wann Bettke ist bei mir.
Bettke geht schnell. Welche Audacity Version? Keine Ahnung. Irgendwas uraltes, was ich vor 3220... Das ist noch die ohne Rootkit drin.
Nee, was war das noch mal? Kein Rootkit. Was haben die noch mal gemacht, wo sie in Unknade gefallen sind? Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Irgendwelche Logging-Schichten haben sie bei Audacity eingebaut. Irgendwas mit Telemetriedaten oder so, wo aber angeblich gar nichts ist.
Oder dann doch, oder dann... Ach, was auch immer. Ja, exzellent. Ja, also. Hey Max, die Lücke, die du angesprochen hast, ist jetzt offiziell.
Meinst du die Razor-Lücke? Oder welche? Die Razor-Lücke war doch schon... Razor. Setup. Das war doch schon vorgestern offiziell.
Ach. Na gut, wenn jetzt sogar schon die neue Schweizer Zeitung gecheckt hat. Guck. Wenn es jetzt die ganzen Zeitungen aufschnappen, dann weißt du,
das ist eigentlich schon old news. Wenn die das mitkriegen, dann ist es eigentlich schon ausgenutzt und vorbei.
Leute, ich habe heute Offstream-Progress-Action gemacht. Ich habe versucht... Ich versuche euch... Moment mal. Big Brain Pain Skills. Mal gucken.
Also, ich versuche euch mal kurz zu erklären, was ich heute gemacht habe. Ich zeige euch das auch im Stream, wenn es funktioniert. Also, guckt mal.
Pass mal auf. Also, das hier ist mein iPhone. Wobei, iPhones sind ein bisschen abgerundet. Das machen wir mal so. So, das ist mein iPhone.
Ja, also. Das ist mein iPhone. Das ist meine Fritzbox. Und das ist ein Decktelefon. Das versteht auch keine Sau, was ich hier male.
Das muss ich beschreiben. Das erkennt man. Was soll das sein? Okay, wartet mal. Wie macht man den Pain überhaupt? Schreib hier.
Fritzbox. Decktelefon. iPhone. So, was ich heute probiert... Ach so, ja. Und dann? Und dann? Das darf man auch nicht vergessen.
Dann mache ich hier so ein Ding. Das da. Das habe ich ja auch noch. Das habe ich ja auch noch. So. Und das ist meine Kamera-Hooftor.
So, und was ich heute versucht habe zu programmieren, ist folgendes. Und es funktioniert auch. Zwar noch nicht hundertprozentig, aber es funktioniert auch.
Also, was ich machen will, ist ja folgendes. Ich habe mir mal eine Tür-Gegensprechanlage per Deck angebunden. Ich mache das jetzt aber stellvertretend mit dem Decktelefon.
Also stellt euch vor, das ist die Tür-Gegensprechanlage, aber zum Testen ist es ein Decktelefon. Also, was ich machen will, ist folgendes.
Ich habe ein Decktelefon, das ist angemeldet an der Fritzbox. So. Ich habe ein iPhone, das hat mit der Fritzbox gar nichts zu tun.
Das hat aber einen ZIP-Account mit Public. Also, das hat einen ZIP-Client drauf mit einem Account im Internet. Das ist jetzt aber nicht das Ding.
So, was ich jetzt machen will, ist, wenn die Türe klingelt, also in dem Fall das Decktelefon. Wenn das Decktelefon klingelt, dann möchte ich, mit was ich selbst programmiert habe,
dass das Ding einen neuen Call macht und den Sound von hier plus die Kamera zu einem ausgehenden ZIP-Call macht zu meinem iPhone.
So, dass ich dann dort Kamera und Sound von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage habe.
Also, was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ist folgendes. Auf meinem Raspberry Pi läuft jetzt ein.NET-Programm. Das ist das hier. Huge Erklärung.
Hier ist er eher reckt anstatt deckt. Kannst du sowas nicht mit Asterisks... Bestimmt, aber selbst programmieren ist einfacher, als dass ich jetzt noch Telefonanlagen lerne.
Also, was ich jetzt gemacht habe, ist folgendes. Der Raspberry Pi mit.NET-Programm meldet sich jetzt an als IP-Telefon an der Fritzbox.
Mit einer internen Nummer. Das ist die interne Nummer. Jetzt kommt Trick 17.
Ich rufe von diesem Decktelefon. Ich stelle euch vor, dass es stellvertret... Moment, die Musik geht mir auf den Sack. Ich brauche irgendwas entspannenderes.
Irgendwas entspannenderes. Ah, Relaxing. Excellent. Huge Relaxing.
Ja, das ist nice. Ah, ich habe zu viele Tabs auf. Null. Brain lag.
Hier ist der Sound. So, okay, jetzt weiter. Danke für die ganzen Subs. Ich bin gerade komplett mit Big Brain konzentriert.
Wen haben wir denn hier? Sebi. Danke für den Sub. Und der Tanser. 26 Monate ist er am Start.
Zwischendurch hat er auch noch Take Viagra Die Hard. Hat auch noch Subs gehabt hier. Big Brain Name und Big Brain Prime Subs heute.
So, also das ist die internen Nummer. Und was jetzt passiert, ist folgendes. Ich wähle... Ich wähle...
Jetzt von hier die Nummer an über Deckt. So, und was jetzt mein.NET Programm macht, ist folgendes.
Das nimmt den Call an, holt sich das Audio daraus, ruft ein Bild von der Kamera ab und macht daraus einen...
Ups, Alter, ist Paint Scheiße. Und macht daraus einen kombinierten Call mit ZIP zu meinem iPhone und in diesem Call sind dann Audio plus Video.
Das hier war ursprünglich nur Audio, das ist ursprünglich nur RTSP Video und ich nehme diesen Call per ZIP an und mache einen neuen ZIP Call, wo dann Audio und Video drin ist.
Ich zeige euch das demnächst mal im Stream, wenn es richtig funktioniert. Es ist einfacher als ich gedacht habe, aber trotzdem ZIP ist wirklich...
Also ZIP, ich weiß nicht, weil sich das ausgedacht hat, dass es wirklich... Da kommst du ja voll wie im Mittelalter.
Nein, mit RTSP hat das nichts zu tun. RTSP, das einzige was RTSP ist, ist das zwischen Kamera und.NET. Was du meinst ist RTP.
RTP ist für Medienübertragung. Genau, ZIP ist das Signaling und RTP ist das für die Daten. So ist das.
Das ist A264 Video innen drin und PCMA Audio. So, so macht es das gerade. Und das funktioniert.
Ich nehme jetzt, es klingelt jetzt bei mir auf dem Handy, ich nehme das an. Was mir das bringt, dass ich unterwegs mit jemanden vor meiner Tür Gegensprechanlage dem zugucken kann und mit dem reden kann.
Und der mich hört. Und ich ihn. Unterwegs. Mobile. So, genau. Das habe ich heute versucht zu basteln und es klappt tatsächlich erstaunlich gut.
Und ich sehe ihn noch. Genau. Und ich sehe ihn noch, was er da macht. Und das richtig Gute ist, ich kann den Call annehmen. Genau, das ist das... Schreiben wir mal hier Tür. So.
Und ich kann hier annehmen und nachdem das ja ein extra Call ist, der mit dem eigentlichen Call nichts zu tun hat, der hier leitet ja nur das Audio weiter, kann ich dem Typ sogar zugucken in diesem Call ohne dass er mich hört.
Dass er mich hört, muss ich erst einen Knopf drücken. Welche Lip hast du benutzt? Die hier. Die ist richtig gut. Die habe ich schon für WebRTC Kram verwendet. Die hier.
Das ist an sich richtig cool. Der hat auch viele Beispiele und sonst wie und das ist top aktuell. Auch der entwickelt gerade. Die hat noch viel mehr Sterne verdient. Also das ist wirklich geil.
Zum Beispiel mal wieder gucken, ob der DPD-Ausliefertyp entweder was sinnlos vor die Tür klatscht, wobei das macht eher Amazon, ohne wieder abhauen, ohne einen Zettel reinzuschmeißen.
Ja alles, wie gesagt, habe ich alles hiermit gemacht. Audio Video ist nach wie vor FFmpeg. Also das Video von der Kamera ist abgerufen per FFmpeg und dann die RAW H264 Frames hier direkt reingehauen.
Weil das Schöne ist, H264 und PCMA kann so gut wie das Audio jedes Endgerät. Ja richtig richtig bigges brain time. Und wisst ihr was das geile ist, dass das über NAT funktioniert, auf Anhieb über NAT.
Also sprich ins Internet raus hier. Hier ist ja noch mein Router dazwischen. Hat auf Anhieb funktioniert, das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Ich hätte gedacht, ich muss irgendwelche NAT Spezialitäten machen, dass das funktioniert.
Ne, du hast nichts verpasst. So, nachdem ich heute nicht lange on bin, ich habe auch nichts großartig geplant, kann ich euch gleich sagen. Also jetzt habe ich euch ja erstmal aufgemalt, was ich heute programmiert habe. Das können wir dann auch im Stream mal ausprobieren zusammen.
Ich glaube das ist was ganz cooles für alle die es brauchen. 99,999999% der Weltbevölkerung braucht sowas natürlich nicht. Aber alle mit einer Videogegensprechanlage plus einer getrennten Kamera, die das mobil empfangen wollen.
Tja, Hetzerstells Fortsetzung, ja ich weiß es noch nicht. Ich wollte ja eigentlich heute machen, aber heute habe ich mich zu sehr mit meinem Progress Projekt aufgehalten. Ja.
So, Bettgeerdetection haben wir hier noch auf. So Leute wir gucken jetzt mal was. Wo ist es? Ich habe mich übelst weggeschmissen.
Ich habe mich übelst weggeschmissen. Ist schon ein bisschen älter. Ist schon ein bisschen älter. Wartet mal. Ist schon ein bisschen älter. Ist von 2016 oder so. Wo sieht man denn, war es hochgeladen von 2018. Ich fand es mega lustig.
240p in 2018, ja. Also eines der besten davon die ich in letzter Zeit, Risitas, die ich in letzter Zeit gesehen habe.
Wir müssen, wir müssen Ahi hören. Leute die Quali ist so schlecht. Ich kann auch nichts dafür. Aber wie gesagt das ist richtig lustig.
Und Chico muss aufhören. Wo ist Chico?
Jetzt aber.
Das ist Agil. Hau raus.
Das wird noch besser. Wer kennt es nicht?
Das wird noch besser.
Wie recht. Backups.
Backups waren halt optional.
Das wird noch besser.